[Music starts] [Audio Description - not captioned]
[L. Aravind Iyer, PhD] Early in my
life, I wanted to be a paleontologist
and that's what actually
led me to molecular biology.
At one level, I could say that I wish to
understand the whole protein universe.
Proteins can be divided into evolutionary units
- is a part of a protein which is preserved
over evolution because natural selection
is maintaining that part for some reason.
And one realization which dawned on us,
starting around the early 90s, and this was a
very profound realization for all of biology,
is that there is a relatively small number of
these evolutionary units of proteins, which we
term domains, which constitutes the entire protein
universe of all organisms across the tree of life.
If we can understand the functions of these units,
then that goes a long way towards
understanding what organisms do.
And given that there are many gaps in
our understanding of what organisms do,
one way to get at it is to
first find all these domains.
The second aspect of it is
predicting functions for them.
The first phase of my research, we
captured most of the low hanging fruit
which were the big families
conserved across all organisms.
Now we are moving on to
the more difficult terrain.
But the difficult terrain
also holds a lot of promise
because many un-understood functions are
hiding within that difficult terrain and
it gives these offshoots in the
form of biotechnological reagents.
There are things like restriction
enzymes, the CRISPR systems,
and DNA modification systems. All of
these have become very popular reagents.
NLM is a world leader in the analysis of
protein sequences, protein structures,
and inferring evolution from
these bits of information.
And this has been a very long-standing
interest of mine so this is the place to be.
[Music fades to silence]